my next guest who is joining me from
yahoo sports he covers both college
football and basketball
for yahoo sports he's also a co-host of
yahoo sports college podcast
uh chris brockman um pete famil when i
asked him if he had a landline you know
we
asked people do you have a landlord can
you call us on a landline it's clear
uh his response to me uh on uh direct
message on twitter quote unfortunately i
can't call you from 1996.
this is his response so i'm assuming
joining us from the best line he's got
in 2020 pete family here on the rich
house y'all repeat
rich i'm good i just told your uh
producer who called me that
smoke signal uh i can do morse code if
you want to communicate
that is available wow you know i
try to be flexible to help here calling
me from 1996
is not right you know what that's not a
bad thing because that means uh michigan
is about to go to the national
championship game the next year so let's
keep talking i guess from 1996
um and let us start with my alma mater
what is
uh the latest best you can tell with
michigan ohio state set for saturday
michigan paused all of its football
activities until
today is michigan back at it or
is saturday's big game with ohio state
in jeopardy
right now pete good good question um i
think the biggest question in the sport
right now this is uh
one of michigan's more relevant moments
in in recent years uh
the the uh sorry just had to have the
pledge
it's all good the all indications i
heard this morning from michigan are
that they're preparing to practice so
you don't want to get too excited about
anything but that is uh
that is a positive uh it's been optimism
and positivity i don't say positive
because that can be taken the
wrong way in 2020 parlance right
positivity
and optimism for michigan to practice
today
uh i don't know if they've decreed that
yet but they were preparing to do so
when i talked to a couple people there
this morning so yeah michigan playing is
a
is a huge key to uh you know a lot of
things in the big ten right now well
a huge key to a lot of things in the big
ten because of the rule that a team
needs to play six games in order to
compete for the conference championship
and uh if they haven't played those many
games then
um one would think uh the college
football playoff committee would not
view that positively with positivity to
use your phrase
what about the concept of barry alvarez
the uh major domo there in wisconsin
and a de facto if you will commissioner
of this league
saying that we could just change the
rule what's the status right there
pete well i just think it's it's obvious
right the big ten is not going to hurt
the big ten for a rule they made up for
no particularly good reason three months
ago right there's a lot of money at
stake at a time when people need money
um with a playoff spot there's also just
prestige and
nothing would would burn the big ten
more than uh
than you know say two sec and two acc
schools
uh or one one acc school and one
moonlighting as an acc school
um getting on getting in the playoffs
like that the big ten is not gonna
self-sabotage
over uh over this so look like
we we talked about this on our yahoo
sports podcast uh
last night and we were laughing just
because of course the big 10 is going to
capitulate to ohio state and what they
need
and i would like to think they would do
it for northwestern or rutgers or
whoever it is
but they are not going to
rule in a way that hurts their best team
or what we
perceive at this point to be their best
team from getting in the playoffs they
need games they're going to get them
games
games will be played so i uh i i'm not
you know i think it's almost like a
foregone conclusion i like barry alvarez
for saying the obvious things out loud
right
we're in an era where especially in
college sports uh i always joke that
it's it's hard to get people to tell you
obvious things well that's obvious so
thank you barry for just saying it out
loud yeah he did and you know with the
ultimate of respect i mean
you know i know nebraska's parents were
very vocal and i know
uh jim harbaugh was vocal about wanting
to play
isn't playing this season at all uh one
in part of capitulation to ohio state
pete
in the big ten yes and
and give give them give them credit for
steering it look the season's been
arousing a rousing success there was a
lot of pessimism
around the sport that it could be pulled
off it hasn't been perfect but
um it it it's happening and it's
happening in large part because
behind the scenes you know people like
gene smith people like ryan day and
again
bill moos scott frost you can go on and
on they weren't they weren't the only
ones who wanted to but there were
there were teams and programs that
weren't excited about playing and
i don't think at this point anyone
anyone regrets uh
this season having been played pete
family yahoo sports here on the rich
eisen show
does coastal carolina's win over byu
crack the lineup here i know i know we
were all very
you know in uh in the media writ large
liking hey giving kudos to byu and
coastal carolina for scheduling each
other on the fly
but does it in in the end does it even
matter if they're not going to expand
off of four games four teams in the
playoffs pete
oh i think it matters i mean what a
great moment for uh
for coastal carolina i've spent a bunch
of time down there over the uh years joe
moglia their old coach has a great story
uh
he was uh you know he made a hundred
million dollars on in in finance and
then
retired and became a college football
coach and has really helped steer that
program
from fcs to one double a so like i don't
know like part of college football like
what i don't want it to become is that
it you're irrelevant if you're not one
of the four
or one of the eight or whatever it ends
up being becoming in the next few years
right like
that was just a great moment on a
college campus and you know the mormons
versus mullets t-shirts like that's what
college football is and is about
you know so i i thought it was awesome
uh
loved the way that you know really with
inferior talent coastal carolina
controlled the game
uh through just running the ball in 14
and 17 play drives and
you know really did really did a great
job limiting zach wilson's opportunities
and
uh yep byu hurt itself with some with
some big plays and i think they uh they
didn't probably value every possession
like a
like a precious gem like you have to do
against schools that control the ball
and control the clock and
coastal came out and what a uh what a
night for the mullets well i mean
i don't want my question to be and and
you you did you did
appropriately respond to it um and i
think i left it out there
so it can be inferred that it doesn't
matter um for
a program like coastal carolina to have
a moment like that
moments are are are wonderful but the
ultimate moment would be
to have coastal carolina go up against
alabama and see how it flies
or clemson or or notre dame and see how
it flies like
and and and that's what i mean i guess
is what i meant to to say
is that we we should just like major
league baseball pete
decided to expand their playoffs in
covet just like the nhl
and the nba coming up with a different
manner in which to
uh to to gain the the playoffs um
in in their bubbles they come up with a
different one the nfl has got a plan
in case it's necessary to change their
playoffs the fact that college football
is right here saying yeah we're
just gonna do the same thing it to me is
insane like
it's a different season there are
different ways in which somebody can win
i'd love to see cincinnati do their
thing i'd love to see coastal carolina
do their thing if they deserve it
and instead they're just gonna be on
some bowl game that maybe i'll watch
i'll be honest
you know that's what i'm saying i guess
what do you know
that's that's a great point college
athletics like
when you really drill down on it like is
is
just some of the least nimble well it
starts with what like
if nfl wants to make a change well it
starts with what roger goodell
owners call roger goodell who do you
call in college sports you call
gene smith to call barry alvarez there's
nobody in charge so
it's hard for six separate entities with
competing interests to all try and
do something like this and you know like
it's been funny because
you talk to people about like changing
the playoff when's the earliest that
could happen
like it's it's all their all the lame
arguments or the same lame arguments
they had against the playoffs that i
wrote about for you know a decade and a
half before they finally changed to a
playoff like it's just
it's the same static institutional
nonsense
and there's just so much bureaucracy and
crap quite frankly in college athletics
that prevents
easy obvious decisions from being made a
couple more for you here uh pete
pete family yahoo sports i don't want
for you too right oh right
uh-huh is it is it in the question i'm
about to ask you about
um uh the rumor the hot rumor that was
uh going
spreading like crazy amongst my uh
friends and uh
fellow alums uh at michigan that that
jim harbaugh is on the verge of getting
a contact
contract extension with michigan is that
the question you're going to ask me pete
it wasn't but i'll answer that to the
best i can and then
i'll follow my answer with a question um
that's been buzzing
um no one's been able to kind of confirm
that but that wouldn't be a surprise and
all along i really didn't think michigan
wanted to part ways with jim harbaugh um
if
if they're gonna do that they'd probably
be wise to do it before they play ohio
state on saturday as that as the outcome
looks fairly predictable even with
obviously
the buckeyes playing with a little bit
of an inferior roster especially on the
offensive line
um but yeah you i have never felt
in this a strong
institutional desire for michigan to
this isn't auburn right like there's a
respect for what harbaugh has done
you look at the job he's done there
holistically um he's won 69
of his games yes he's revived revenues
from you know two pretty down
eras back to back with uh with with
brady and rich kids
graduate they're not they're not in
trouble a lot at all
no there's uh and i understand you know
i'm sure the school president
absolutely adores that in jim harbaugh
no question about that
yeah and i think the school president
because it's
it's a university that has varied other
interests is almost
uh yep there's maybe a little sense of
ambivalence towards the football team
having it down here because it's a
pandemic and
you're revolting and i think you're spot
on and that's a good thing that's a
compliment
to them that's not a you know that's not
that's not knocking them like they don't
care enough it's like yeah there's a
you're trying to run a multi-billion
dollar institution in a pandemic so
there's other you know so there's
potentially other
other priorities um what i want to ask
you is this
from your chair rich you're obviously
far more plugged in into the nfl
do you think there's a market for jim
harbaugh right now in the nfl i think
the jets uh
i i know woody johnson has been very um
enamored
uh with jim and by jim and
um and he's coming back um uh
officially in a couple of weeks uh from
his ambassadorship
uh overseas that's the total wild card i
don't know if the bears would be
i don't know what the bears are going to
do um i think the lions are already
uh focusing on uh the 49ers defensive
coordinator and robert sala that you see
uh he's from dearborn i i don't know how
much of a market there would be
for for uh harbaugh in the pros right
now
i don't know yeah no that's that's would
be my sussing it out right now
yeah that's my sense too from from
calling around i did a little bit
earlier
this season but there are you know
there's gonna be seven eight nfl jobs
probably by the uh by the end of this
whole thing so
it's uh it it's interesting would he be
better off
taking a year off i don't think so he
loves to coach pete you know that you
know he's a total and that's
and that's the thing that was the most
outrageous aspect about the whole
waving the white flag using cove as a
shield
you know uh what michigan is installed
is a 30-point underdog
or something insane like that for this
week and then let's just
use covid to avoid the inevitable
destruction i mean that is so
antithetical to who this guy is
you say what you will about him saying
don't eat chicken because he's a nervous
bird or whatever
all that stuff to say that he wants to
duck competition is
insane insane pete
i agree with that i agree with that jim
harvey i mean i covered him at stanford
he was he was a blast back
then it was pre pre-social media but the
stuff he would do and say and the way he
he not only needled pete carroll back
when usc was a roaring dynasty but then
he went and beat him as a 42 coin under
no he's his competitive chops uh his
competitive chops can't be questioned i
just
i just question the team right now i
just don't think it's very talented
just and i don't see a i don't see a
clear path out of this for him there
because of just the distinct town like
maryland has more talent than michigan
right now
you know i feel like i should be one of
those cnn or
uh fox news or or msnbc anchors who say
we should just leave it there we'll have
we have to leave it there
up against it but i do have a couple
more questions real quick hitters uh
was there any any there there with urban
meyer in texas
pete i think it was a it was
sort of a an open secret that was a that
was a courtship but it's
but it's not going to happen okay and
trevor lawrence um
sitting there uh knowing that uh there
are two teams that can have him right
now
unless there's somebody that comes out
of nowhere and gives the old
mike ditka king's ransom to try and come
draft him
um he he is done at clemson right he is
not going to sit there and say the jets
are such a dumpster fire
i don't want to go what are you hearing
about that well it's a good question
trevor i have a lot of respect for
trevor lawrence and what he's done there
how he's evolved
um it's really hard so when they
throttled
alabama in the title game his freshman
year from that moment on
he was the number one pick in this
upcoming draft and it's
really hard when your expectation is
generationally great to live up to it
and even
succeed it and he's done it all while
you know really developing into a really
engaging young man who's
charitable he was more thoughtful about
black lives matter than his coach was
i mean he's really been impressive in
every way and
it's a long way and he asked for quick
hitters to say like i don't know i
i don't i think he'll go to the nfl
draft because that's probably the the
smart fiscal thing to do
he doesn't seem to have the personality
he's he's likely not going to go with
like a big high-powered agency that
could help orchestrate something like
that like i think
he'll go and try to give his best shot
that's that's his personality
so you never know things can things can
change but that that's the way i see
trevor lawrence playing out right now
pete we've got time between then i'm
blessed
in new jersey we've got a lot of time
between uh
between uh then and and now and uh
appreciate the time thanks
uh greatly and we'll we'll chat over the
next couple weeks as things begin to
heat up
thank you awesome rich appreciate it you
gotta that's uh that's speed demo right
there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here